in this video we'll be explaining all of
sukuna's forms in Jiu Jitsu kaisen we'll
start with his original form from 1 000
years ago and in the later parts of the
video we'll be covering some of his more
recent Godly forms ryoming sukuna is the
strongest Jujutsu sorcerer in history
regarded as the Undisputed king of
curses many Jiu Jitsu Sorcerers of the
Golden Age gave their all against him
but ultimately fell one after another
sakuna's past appearance is described as
a demon with four arms and two faces
although we don't know much about
sukuna's past life we know that he was
selfish cold-hearted immoral and
exceptionally sadistic he was also well
aware of his immense power and was quite
arrogant about him toying with his
opponents and proclaiming superiority
over them even after his death zakuna
managed to keep on living by
transforming himself into cursed objects
a state where he split his power into 20
indestructible fingers one finger sakuna
during episode 1 in order to gain
strength and fight pursed Spirits Yuji
swallowed one of sakuna's fingers
therefore Reviving sukuna from his 1000
years long sleep as you can imagine
tsukuna couldn't have been more excited
to be Flesh and Bones again although he
didn't appear to be that strong and Gojo
effortlessly defeated him this swarm of
sukuna is not to be underestimated as he
still had all of his combat experience
and understanding of cursed energy from
when he was a human another important
thing to mention is that sukoon now
wasn't in full control of yuji's body at
this point which also greatly limited
his strength sukuna malevolent try only
a few days later Yuji ate another one of
sukuna's fingers although this made
sukuna much stronger Yuji was still in
perfect control of his body and didn't
let sukuna take over however during the
battle at the Detention Center Yuji had
to allow sukuna to take over since he
wasn't strong enough to defeat the curse
himself this is where we saw the
fragment of sukuna's true power as he
used his domain expansion for the first
time malevolent Shrine this domain Grand
sukuna a guaranteed hit and the ability
to relentlessly slash apart anything
inside it until nothing Remains the
thing that makes malevolent Shrine
different from other domains is that it
doesn't create a separate space using a
barrier instead it affects the whole
area around sakuna it's a truly Divine
technique and using it he effortlessly
defeated the finger Bearer a special
grade curse slashing it into countless
pieces after defeating it tsukuna also
ate the third finger making him even
more powerful although sakuna seems
Unstoppable at this point next forms on
the list are infinitely times more
powerful than this one but before we get
to those I recently found something
amazing that I just have to share with
you guys Factor 75 picture this you are
at home checking out the new episode of
jjk and you suddenly get really hungry
you now have two options spend two hours
in the kitchen making a decent meal or
just order some junk food and call it a
day neither of these seem that appealing
right well there's actually a third
option Factor 75 that will literally
change your life their service allows
you to order nutritious high quality
meals ready to eat in minutes these
meals will make sure you always have
something healthy on hand so you can
stay focused on what you love to do
whether you are a vegan vegetarian or
just want to eat more protein to build
muscle Factor has something for everyone
as you can choose between 27 plus
different meal options each week click
my link in the description or scan the
QR code on the screen to order your
Factor meal now and if you enter my
special code you'll even get 50 off your
first box 15 fingers sakuna during
Shibuya Arc Yuji was fed another finger
by ghetto's subordinates this along with
the finger Yuji ate during the death
painting Arc now puts him at five
fingers in total however shortly after
that something crazy happens Joko
appears carrying 10 additional fingers
and feed them all to Yuji at the same
time this now makes a total of 15
fingers which was enough to make sukuna
take control of yuji's body sookuna
politely asked ghetto subordinates what
they want him to do saying they both get
one finger's worth of his time naturally
they ask him to kill the fake ghetto but
sakuna just kills them both anyway after
that we're treated to a full-scale fight
between sukuna and Joko and as you would
expect shukuna completely overwhelms
jogo in every way possible the poor guy
try using his domain experience as he
knew sakuna's domain would overwhelm his
at this point sukuna is just toying with
Joko and even starts using fire attacks
in order to make it easier for him
however jogo is still overpowered and
just before he dies sukuna tells him
that he had a lot of fun fighting him
and that he should be proud I mean we
all knew sukuna would eventually win but
no one expected the difference in their
power to be this big at the end of the
day jogo was the strongest special grade
curse in kenjaku's group following this
fight sukuna realizes that megumi has
unleashed the strongest shikigani from
the 10 Shadows technique Divine General
maharaga this guy is kinda a big deal as
nobody in the history of the zening clan
has ever been able to defeat him
although sukuna now has the power of 15
fingers maharagus punch sends him flying
across the whole city you see maharaga
has the ability to quickly adapt to all
attacks making him pretty much immune to
anything thrown at him the only way to
defeat him is to use a powerful new
attack but he has never seen before and
kill him before he has any time to react
this sounds impossible right well sukuna
does exactly that instantly killing
mahuraga with a mysterious Firebase
attack so during the span of a few
chapters tsukuna has been able to defeat
the strongest special grade curse in
kenjaku's group and kill the strongest
shikigami that no one else in the
history has been able to defeat and he
still has three forms stronger than this
one sakuna the 10 Shadows ten percent
okay so you remember how during the
first season Yuji made a binding vow
with sukuna in exchange for bringing him
back to life The Pact allows sukuna to
take full control of yuji's body for one
minute as long as he doesn't hurt anyone
also because of the exact conditions of
The Vow Yoshi forgot all about it the
reason I'm mentioning this is because
sukuna used this vow to get even
stronger than he was you see during the
calling game megomi was devastated when
he learned that his sister is now
actually a reincarnated sorcerer named
takes advantage of this and activates
the binding vow gaining full control of
yuji's body for one minute he uses this
time to rip one of yuji's fingers and
force it down megumi's throat it's a
gamble but it works he manages to
transfer his Consciousness into megumi
now there's not much difference between
this form and the previous form we
covered except for the fact that sukuna
can now use the 10 Shadows technique he
immediately showcases his new techniques
by spawning a massive demonic version of
the new and attacks Maki and takaba
however while he is not paying attention
Hannah sneaks up behind him and attacks
him with her curse technique which burns
sukuna and causes his skin to tear this
is the part where sukuna shows his
cunningness as he starts talking to Hana
in a pleasant voice pretending to be
megumi and Embraces her it's enough to
fool Hana which gives sukuna the chance
to bite her and drop her on the ground
at this point sukuna realizes that he
doesn't yet have full control over
megumi's body and that his cursed energy
is restricted to only 10 percent however
this doesn't bother him as he is
confident that he can still defeat both
Yuji and Maki even in this state the two
Sorcerers proceed to attack sukuna at
the same time but he handles them both
very efficiently keeping the fight at a
stalemate before we cover sukuna's
strongest form in the entire story let's
quickly go over the 10 Shadows tsukuna
at a hundred percent after the fight
with Maki and Yuji sukuna proceeds to
take a bath setup for him by urame and
kenjaku immersing himself in curses and
other evils in order to completely
submerge megumi's Soul granting him
stronger control of his body and curse
energy but even after this tsukuna still
isn't satisfied and decides to kill
eurozu a sorcerer who is currently
inhabiting the body of megumi's sister
this makes megumi's Soul sink even
deeper into despair granty sukuna full
control of his body and cursed energy
full power sukuna after his fight with
yorozu sukuna and Gojo agreed to a duel
on December 24th in the meantime sukuna
eats four more fingers which were given
to him by urame this means that sukuna
now ate 19 fingers in total however one
was still missing in order to compensate
for this tsukuna eats his original
mummified body from the high in the era
which finally puts him at 100 of his
power with this he is finally ready to
face Gojo the fight is about as crazy as
you'd expect and the two of them go on
to engage in several domain expansion
battles using his full power tsukuna is
easily able to match Gojo's domain and
even breaks it multiple times this is
the first time in the story anyone has
been able to beat Gojo like this but the
battle is not over yet and after some
trial and error Gojo figures out a way
to break sukuna's domain he does this by
shrinking his domain to the size of a
basketball which in return makes it much
tougher and harder to break however this
is sukuna's strongest form we're talking
about here and after around three
minutes he manages to break Gojo's
domain again and free himself although
the battle seems balanced at this point
the important thing to mention is that
sukuna hasn't yet attempted to use his
innate curse technique which means he is
still not using the full extent of his
powers imagine being so strong that even
against Gojo you don't go all out now
you are probably wondering how is sukuna
even able to physically attack Gojo
shouldn't his Infinity stop all incoming
attacks in theory yes but sukuna has an
answer to this you see throughout their
fight sakuna uses the ability called
domain amplification which makes an aura
of cursed energy around him and can
neutralize Gojo's Infinity when he comes
into contact with it tsukuna also
showcased his Mastery over 10 Shadows
technique by spawning General maharaga
and even agito a fusion Beast that
consists of four different shikigamis if
that's not enough he was also shown
capable of using blood manipulation
surprising even chozo in this form
sukuna seems Unstoppable and the
scariest thing is he still hasn't shown
us his innate technique why has he been
hiding his signature technique for so
long and how strong is it well we'll
have to wait a bit more until the show
reveals exactly what it is but it'll
undoubtedly make sukuna even stronger
than he currently is if you can imagine
that click on this video where we
explained all of Gojo's forms in Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen go on click it